what I want to do in this video is dig a
little bit deeper in this marginal
product revenue curve and really make
sure we understand what it's telling us
that it really is the marginal benefit
curve for this firm and the video we
constructed it at this firm is a car
wash and also how we can use this to
think about what's a rational number of
people for this firm to hire and just as
a reminder this horizontal axis here
this is a quantity of labor per hour so
this is people per hour that are working
at the firm people per hour and the
vertical axis here the marginal product
revenue that you could view as the
marginal dollars or the incremental
dollars that you're getting per person
per hour per person person per hour per
hour and to just verify that it's
telling us the same thing visually that
this table told us right up here we can
think about what is the marginal how
much incremental revenue do we get from
hiring that first person so what we
could do is we can multiply the quantity
of people which is 1 times the average
times the average increment the average
marginal product revenue that we get
from one person or I should say the
average we get going from zero to one
person and the average is 25 the average
is 25 and the reason why I set it that
way is you can imagine a reality we're
getting 1/10 of a person you get a value
higher than 25 and you might say how do
I get a tenth of a person well what if
one person shows up every 10 days and
then you get a little little less
benefit as you get closer and closer to
a whole person per hour but on average
as we go from zero to one person we are
getting 25 dollars of value or 25
dollars of marginal revenue per person
per hour and so if you wanted to figure
out what's the total marginal revenue
that we got from this person right over
here the total incremental revenue that
this is allowing us to get well it's the
one person times the average marginal
product revenue which is 25 so that
would give us the area of this rectangle
right of
there which would be $25 now and you
would really have to do a little bit of
calculus to fully appreciate it but I
think you can look at it geometrically
that also happens to be given that this
is a line that our curve our marginal
product revenue is a is a line right
over here that the area under this
rectangle is going to be the same thing
as the area under the orange curve the
orange curve for Z between 0 and 1/2 is
above this rectangle and between 1/2 and
1 it is below the rectangle and the area
above is the same as the area below so
$25 is also the area is also the area
under under this curve and that's
essentially how much benefit the firm is
getting from hiring from going from zero
to one person they're getting $25 of
benefit
now how much benefit they get going from
one to two people well going from one to
two our change in quantity of people per
hour is one and then our average
marginal product revenue going from one
to two people is $20 so it is $20 and so
the area is 1 times 20 and that's also
going to be the same as the area under
the curve so the area under the curve
right over there is going to be 20
likewise the area under the curve if we
want to say how much hot what's the
marginal product revenue we get going
from 2 to 3 people well the average
height here we'd essentially just say
well what is the area between 2 and 3
and we can figure out that area by
saying well the average height the
average height is 15 multiply 15 so this
height the average height is 15 x 15
times 1 you get $15 $15 of benefit
between 3 & 4 the average height is 10
the average height is 10 so you get 10
times 1 you get $10 of benefit would be
the area under the curve right over here
$10 of benefit and then the area under
the curve there by the same argument is
$5 is $5 of benefit now we've given this
this is just telling us the revenue
we're getting but it's really not
telling us it's really not telling us
what is the optimal or the rational
number of employees to hire to do that
we have to think about the cost per
employee
the marginal cost that we are actually
incurring and I mentioned earlier that
this is a competitive firm and when I
mentioned it before I talked about it
being competitive in terms of the car
wash market so it was a competitive
supplier but let's assume that it is
also a competitive buyer in the labour
market so these are two different these
are two different markets and I want to
clarify in the car wash market in car
wash market we are competitive we are a
competitive supplier or I guess we could
say we are seller of car washes in the
labor market in the labor market our
firm is a competitive is a competitive
buyer now I'll do a little bit of an
aside here because when we talk about
suppliers we there's there's the
competitive suppliers where there's many
undifferentiated people who are
supplying some type of good or service
and the opposite of that was a monopoly
so so non competitive non-competitive as
a seller we call that a monopoly if we
had a non-competitive buyer so if you
had many sellers but only one big buyer
that could have a lot of market
influence and we haven't done a deep
analysis of that yet that word just so
you know it and doesn't you know you're
not taken by surprise if someone says it
just it means monopsony or the word is
monopsony monopsony not relevant to this
video we are the opposite of a monopoly
in the labor market we there are we're
assuming that we are competitive buyer
there are many many many many many
buyers here so we essentially just have
to take the market wages and we are also
the opposite of a monopoly in the
carwash market we're assuming that we
are one of many competitive sellers
monopoly means only one seller monopsony
means one powerful buyer but the whole
reason why I'm saying that it's we are
competitive in the labor market is I'm
assuming that we're just going to have
to take the market wages so the market
wage for the type of labor we're hiring
so the market wage and we're just going
to take that the market wage is going to
be let's just say it is $10 per hour $10
per hour and given that what is a
rational number of people to hire well
that first person we hire we're getting
$25 of benefit the marginal cost of them
and we can actually draw a marginal cost
curve the marginal cost curve will just
be flat right here at $25 it will just
be my started will be flat here at $10
that's how much it costs us if we hire
one person it costs us the area would be
$10 if we hire two people the area would
be between zero and two and under the
curve which would be 20 or you could say
the increment from going from one to two
people is another $10 so we're going to
two to three people this area right over
here is another $10 if you go from three
to four people this area under here is
another $10 under this green curve so
does it make sense to hire that first
person sure you're going to get $25 in
revenue and you're going to have $10 in
wages so you're going to have $15 of
benefit so you definitely want to hire
one person does it hire it make sense to
hire that second person well the
marginal product revenue is going to be
$20 from that second person your
marginal cost from that second person is
$10 you're going to make $10 on that
first on that second person so you
should hire that second person the third
person you're going to make $15 off them
they're going to cost three they're
going to cost you $10 so you're going to
and this is all in a per hour basis
you're going to make $5 so you should
hire that the fourth person well now
it's interesting the fourth person
you're going to you're going to make $10
total off of the fourth person but
you're not but you're also going to have
to pay $10 for that fourth person so it
doesn't make sense for you to hire a
toll another total fourth person now if
you could it could make sense for you to
hire another half person maybe someone
who shows up every other day if this
still holds or maybe someone who shows
up for half an hour or maybe someone who
is doing this job and also operating the
cash register and they're kind of going
in between because for a half person it
does make sense a half person is going
to cost $5 and their marginal benefit is
going to be the area under the curve
between this point and this point and so
we get so the profit from that person
the the net benefit we're going to get
is going to be this area right over here
so it would be rational to get them but
what you're seeing is it makes sense to
keep increasing the quantity demanded it
keeps makes sense to keep hiring more
and more people until the marginal
benefit or another way of saying the
marginal
product revenue curve is equal to the
marginal cost curve after that point the
person's costs are higher than their
benefits and you wouldn't want to hire
them